[Music]
between the summer of 1963 and the
autumn of 1965 something terrible
happened here that shocked a nation it
would come to forever define this
stretch of moorland on the outskirts of
Manchester as a place touched by evil
five children all abducted tortured and
murdered all but one of them buried here
in the marshy peat bogs
have saddled with more their killers
with their blank faces would become
instantly recognizable as the killer
couple Ian Brady and Myra Hindley
Brady's death to cancer at the age of 79
would bring this story to an end if it
wasn't for one big question the body of
Keith Bennett their third victim has
never been found
despite his mother begging to reveal her
son's resting place he knows where he is
and needs Emily all these years now
that's a super he's got rats and I have
not and it's not fair on me the walls
Keith's body was still missing he still
had that's its focus of attention and I
think he enjoyed that and it makes you
wonder whether he just wanted to torture
the family right to the very end he
doesn't use the words I'm sorry he said
that he says that those are meaningless
were
I have always been implacably opposed to
be - couple of words but I would have
made an exception in the cases at least
[Music]
morning after the death of Britain's
most notorious criminal and a single
bouquet of fresh flowers is placed near
to a shrine devoted to Keith Bennett who
saddled with more Heath was just 12
years old when he was abducted and
murdered by Hindley and Brady his body
buried somewhere here although it's
never been found
I've covered the story of the Moors
Murders for 15 years only a handful of
journalists to have written to and
received letters from Ian Brady and hope
that we can begin to understand why he
did what he did but the truth is he's
much of a mystery and death as he was
invited
Ian Brady now takes to his grave the
truth about Keith Bennett's whereabouts
the serial killer had always hinted that
he had not forgotten where he buried the
little boy
it was a dark murderous secret and it
has haunted the families of his victims
ever since he's been its mother when he
never gave up hope that she would one
day find her son in her last interview
with me she begged Brady to reveal
Keith's final resting place give me a
chance to get my dad back before
anything happens to me because I want
him buried before even Brady dad to let
him know that he's the one that's got
the main key and he can give it me all
the police all the press and they can
tell the police and go and search for
him when he died in 2012 not knowing
where her son was buried
for the family to have closure would
mean finding Keith and giving him a
family burial and that would at least
give them some peace they could never
forget forget Keith could never forgive
in Brad year Myra Hindley but at least
that would give him some closes closure
and they can get on with the lives and
whilst Keith's body was still missing
and questions were being asked of him he
still had that focus of attention and I
think he enjoyed that and it makes you
wonder whether he you just wanted to
torture the family right to the very end
it was level it's just control and
manipulation from a psychological
perspective Ian Brady had a personality
disorder and we would label the
personality disorder that he had as
psychopathy he showed all the classic
symptoms of somebody who was
psychopathic in other words he was
narcissistic egoistic he was very
controlling he was desperate for
attention he find it very difficult to
show any empathy for the suffering of
others even as a child
Ian Brady was regarded as a secretive
outsider born in one of the roughest
slums in Glasgow he grew up with an
interest in sadism but after meeting
Myra Hindley that escalated often what's
motivating the killer couple is
something that psychologists call a
folly ardour literally a madness shared
by two whereby each of the two partners
convince each other in the beliefs that
they have goading each or other on to go
further and further in their warped
thinking often in a killer couple you
will find that there's a dominant and a
subservient and for me it was quite
clear that Brady this autodidactic would
read Nietzsche and desaad was the
dominant of the killer couple their
killing began with sixteen-year-old
Pauline Reade lured into Hindley's car
and taken to the moor to me
Brady Pauline was murdered and buried
there
next came 12 year old John kilbride a
clever young man good at football
he loved to be with his three younger
brothers he just didn't come on John I
could see my mother getting worried them
tearooms was five six o'clock it should
have been all he just didn't come home
when he got that laser and then she's
out to the neighbors and then down - to
market who can then all the neighbors
are out looking and the banks we came to
the police them and they idly thin
escalating from Berlin
John killbride had been lured into Myra
Hindley's van and driven to the more his
body would not be found for another two
years he'd been sexually assaulted and
strangled remember they remember it very
clear the night they turned out was John
Shu the wincle poker I remember well and
the other scream downstairs and they
were made out dog the scream not long
they want us so we dinner like a days
they were horrible it raw long it you
know in them it mother out to go down to
cry dealt with her to identify Johnny it
was just horrible to sing them on the
voice were to see a decline into torture
it's what the person she was you know
she never came over ever ever ever came
over a 10-year old Leslie and Downey's
voice was recorded by Brady as she
begged in vain for her life when he and
Hendley finally came to court such
details provoked an outrage scarcely
witnessed before or since
they were the first ones really to
escape capital punishment after the
abolition of it in the mid sixties
there's
first trial after after that way it
wasn't available to the judge I have
always been implacably opposed to the
true capital punishment but I would have
made an exception in the cases of these
two more than 20 years after their
conviction Brady and Hindley were
escorted back to saddle with more where
Pauline reeds remains were found in
Ashworth psychiatric hospital on
Merseyside Brady spent many years on
hunger strike but being force-fed by
staff in 2013 he argued before a
mental-health tribunal that he wasn't
mentally ill and should be allowed to
starve himself to death he failed in his
bid it was claimed that he and Brady
would one day reveal the location of
Keith Bennett's body those who knew him
well
are skeptical I think so far as Franklin
K Keith Bennett's body whatever he knew
about the situation and the possible
location would have been sorted out in
the 1980s I do feel very very sorry for
the family and indeed I've had
situations where I've been on the other
side in a similar situation to motives
of victims whose bodies haven't been
found and the anguish is considerable
but that doesn't mean that in this
particular case he had the Animus son he
seemed to imply that he would know for
example where the body of Keith Bennett
was buried but we have no real evidence
that by the stage that he was engaging
in those kinds of statements that he
truly did know where he had buried
Keith's body but again this formed part
of his narcissistic personality disorder
whereby he wanted he craved attention
and by implying that he knew who Eric
where Keith's body was he got that
attention
it is the end of a dark chapter in
British criminal history there is still
hope that somewhere in this remote place
lies the body of Keith Bennett and that
one day he will be found
Martin skynews